meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
liebe transgender weil nach weihnachten
das ist auch die zeit der dankbarkeit
demut ist das zauberwort sich über die
kleinen dinge freuen 2018 geht zu ende
das heißt wir haben die hälfte der
amtszeit von donald trump geschafft ohne
einen einzigen weltkrieg und dabei sind
doch alle guten dinge drei
da ist mir einer für opa okay überhaupt
man über sie doch bei all den billigen
trump witzen welches profunde
allgemeinwissen dieses meerschweinchen
mit dem gewöhnt als frisur hat fragte
ihn irgendwas die antwort ist immer
lustig ja ja wenn in kalifornien der
wald brennt dann denkt der doofe ließe
klimawandel ein donald dagegen erkennt
sofort das wahre problem im us forstwirt
viel zu wenig gefegt komisch dass ich da
der finnische präsident nicht wirklich
daran hat solche tipps gegeben zu haben
hauptsache in kalifornien wird jetzt
täglich mal wird durch den wald
gebeutelt durch gesagt weil wir ja wir
sollten uns alle vor der fleiß biene
trump verneigen er macht so viel handels
kriege anzetteln schweigegeld für porno
stars zahlen einwanderer kinder in
käfige sperren wie schaffe das nur ohne
burnout ja plus natürlich dieser dolle
frieden mit nordkorea
wobei ist da auch eine brenzlige
situation gab die um ein haar ein
atomkrieg ausgelöst hätte
achten sie hier mal auf kim jong uns
gesicht
die couragierte der arme kommunen erst
in diesem moment erfahrener ich bin ja
fit hatte ihm vorher niemand gesagt kim
jong-un und donald trump die romanze des
jahres ein wahrer traum booms und dafür
gibt es von der heute show nicht einfach
irgendeinen voll forst nein es gibt den
pfosten
herzlichen glückwunsch ministerpräsident
das ist dein licht
[Musik]
und da
zu
wie
[Musik]
durch
und 10
ja
fri
von m
total verarscht die ganze welt über die
ich nun alt
[Musik]
donald
vielleicht löst dieses grundproblem in
nächster zeit ja die natur denn du
ubs
[Musik]
mal so
nein
[Musik]
so
die
deine zu
[Musik]
mehr
[Applaus]
[Musik]